Oh, j'en ai marre d'écrire tout seul.
Mais joueur du grenier qui est pas là
quoi. Ah [ __ ] !
[Applaudissements]
Mais qu'est-ce que tu faisais dans les
chiottes ? Pourquoi tu as mis aussi
longtemps ? Ben à ton avis, je testais
un jeu de merde.
Ah mais ça tombe bien parce que si tu
veux un jeu de merde, j'en ai un jeudi
pour toi hein.
Ah ben merci dis donc. Benah tu as vu là
il y a un chat.
Ben ouais, il y a un chat.
Oh non, il a encore mangé.
[Musique]
On a pas un peu exagéré sur la mise en
scène là ? Ouais, tu penses ?
[Musique]
1 2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le, c'est reparti pour une nouvelle
vidéo et ce coup-ci en fait, j'avais
J'ai envie de vous parler d'un genre qui
est assez peu connu. Mais avant ça, je
voudrais vous rappeler en fait une
situation qu'on a presque tous oublié.
Cit c'estel à quel point tout était
différent à l'époque quand on avait pas
internet. Je veux dire, prenez par
exemple les jeux vidéos. Concrètement,
il y avait que trois moyens de se
renseigner sur un jeu avant de
l'acheter. À l'époque, il y avait les
magazines et encore je crois que les
magazines c'était plutôt sur la période
16 bits que 8 bits. Il y avait les
quelques rares émissions de jeux vidéo à
la télé et enfin il y avait le pire des
moyens c'était de se fier à la jaquette.
Alors oui, c'est très difficile
aujourd'hui en 2011 d'imaginer qu'on
pouvait acheter des jeux en se fiant
uniquigement à la tronche de la
jaquette. Mais pourtant c'était souvent
le cas et le problème c'est qu'étant
gamin, ben tu te faisais souvent avoir
par les conneries qui avaient marqué au
dos des jaquettes, quoi. Bah
franchement, on va faire un jeu. Je
prends des jaquettes au hasard et chaque
fois que je lis une grosse connerie, je
bois un coup.
[Musique]
En fait, ce genre de mensonge, c'était
surtout vrai pour les jeux un peu genre
simulation, vous savez. Regardez ça.
Silent de service, un jeu que
bizarrement beaucoup de gens que je
connais ont eu. Regardez la jaquette.
Bam ! Là, il y a un sous-marin. Ça
explose derrière. Il y a un bateau en
feu. Ça a l'air énorme.
Très bien. Ben, c'est pas aussi
dynamique que j'aurais pu le croire en
regardant la jaquette. à priori. Mais
bon hein, en même temps, tu me diras,
c'est un jeu de sous-marin, hein. Ça
peut pas avoir non plus être super
dynamique, mais bon, ça a besoin d'être
aussi mou. Bon ben, on peut aller aussi
par exemple sur le pont du sous-marin.
Alors, c'est très complet, hein. Il y a
l'état du sous-marin, il y a la carte
générale évidemment hein qui t'indique
les objectifs. Il y a aussi bah, il y a
des trucs et et des machins. Bah là, je
sais pas, vous voyez par exemple là, on
voit que la batterie est à zéro. Euh le
F et le N tournent en rond. Le knot est
à zéro et les diodes vertes et rouges
clignotent. Et ça euh ça je bah je sais
pas ça ça bouge pas. C'est je sais pas
c'est peut-être un autocollant. Voilà.
Bah j'ai absolument aucune idée de
l'utilité de tout ce bordel mais
heureusement je m'en fous hein de toute
façon. Bah la seule chose que j'ai
compris c'est que le but du jeu a priori
c'est de tuer des bateaux ennemis. Oui
ça là je sais qu'à priori ça ressemble à
quatre pixels de merde mais ouvrez vos
chakras et dans votre cœur vous verrez
que c'est un bateau. Voilà. Ben je vais
tirer un missile.
OK.
Bon, ça part de travers, mais c'est
normal, je suppose. Je sais pas. Ou
alors c'est peut-être un truc connu des
sous-mariniers, je sais pas. Genre règle
numéro 1, les missiles part toujours à
gauche. Voilà, c'est peut-être ça ou
c'est simplement que ce jeu c'est de la
merde. Je sais pas, c'est l'un des deux.
Oh [ __ ] mais ça m arrivé.
Oui. Allô ? C'est bon, le missile il
bouge plus là. Il fait quoi ? Dis donc,
tu as pas la barre qui a poussé là ?
Mais oui, mais c'est parce que ce jeu
s'éternise.
Bon euh ben histoire de meubler, le
temps que la torpille arrive, on va
mettre une petite musique.
[Musique]
Ah, très joli. Flut. Merci. Merci.
Tenez par exemple situation typique du
jeu. J'arrive avec la carte sur un
ennemi. Il est beaucoup trop loin donc
j'essaie de m'approcher.
[Musique]
Oui, c'est pour de vrai. C'est vraiment
accéléré h fois là. H fois. Je vous jure
ce jeu il est il est lent. Il est si
lent que je suis en service.
[Musique]
Oh mes oreilles. Je t'avais dit
d'arrêter ce genre de blague aussi. Je
sais pas mais au moin ils auraient pu
prévoir la possibilité d'accélérer le
jeu en temps réel pour rejoindre ces
bateaux là qu'on voit au fond de
l'écran. J'ai mis 20 minutes 20 minutes
à rien faire d'autre que de regarder
l'écran sans rien branler. tu peux
toucher à rien parce que dès que tu
descends dans la cale pour faire autre
chose pour regarder les les jauges, les
cartes, les machins, ça suspend le
temps. Donc tu es obligé de rester sur
l'écran du périscope sans rien [ __ ]
vers là. Voilà cet écran là pendant 20
minutes, rien d'autre. Mais mais pour un
gamin, ça c'est pas intéressant. Enfin,
c'est intéressant pour personne même.
Comment tu veux vendre un jeu simulateur
comme ça ? Ça mentir, c'est impossible.
Aucun gamin normal n'achèterait un jeu
comme ça s'il savait à l'avance à quoi
s'attendre. Et regarde comment il
t'envoie du sang aux États-Unis, hein.
Ah sérieux là, je mets un compteur du
nombre d'images du jeu qu'on voit dans
cette pub. Regardez bien.
OK, une image et encore tu as rien
compris parce que c'est super court.
Deux images,
trois images et c'est tout. La pub
d'imag de jeu. Quelle bande de brigant.
Non mais remarque, c'était forcé.
Comment tu aurais voulu faire une pub
honnête avec un jeu comme ça ? Bilan de
service. Tu mets le jeu, cherche tes
ennemis
et ne fais rien.
J'ai dit rien, rien du tout. Voilà, tu
attends.
Voilà pour ce jeu. Donc maintenant, je
crois quand même que les jeux les plus
connus en simulation, c'était quand même
tout ce qui était simulation de vol, que
ce soit avion ou hélicoptère. Là aussi
par exemple, on est nombreux à cette
refit carottes en ayant vu le film Top
Gun, acheter le jeunesse et finalement à
galérer comme des chiens à
l'atterrissage sur le porte-avion. Alors
les jeux de simulation aérienne
franchement mais il y en a mais des
centaines, c'est tout le temps la même
chose en plus je veux dire. Alors il y a
bien quelques jeux quand même qui ont
essayé de rajouter un petit truc un peu
original mais franchement ou alors
c'était complètement inutile ou alors
c'était de la merde. Tiens, regarde ce
jeu par exemple Infiltrator. Pour moi ce
jeu c'est l'exemple parfait du pourquoi
les simulations aériennes je trouve ça
chiant. En fait, dans ce jeu, ils ont
voulu faire un truc qui a bien trop
compliqué et au final, du coup, ben ils
ont fait n'importe quoi.
OK. Alors, donc tout commence par une
mise en situation, hein. On nous
explique que les méchants sont très
méchants, euh qu'il faut trouver leur
base, que l'ennemi s'appelle le leader
fou, qu'il est vraiment pas content. Et
oui, non, je sais pas non plus pourquoi
le leader fou, c'est un orc, je me
demanderai pas. Alors, c'est parti.
Oui. Bon, OK, ça bouge pas. Ah !
Non B non select non start OK c'est
start pour démarrer. Bon très bien déjà
pour décoller. Première galère bouton
haut. OK.
Bouton bas non plus.
Gauche et droite. Mais non évidemment
c'est pas ça. [ __ ] je réessaye bas.
[ __ ] mais je e mais c'est un truc de
fou ça. Allez. Ou alors je suis con
sérieux. Mais le seul truc que j'ai
trouvé en fait pour décoller cet
appareil, c'est d'effleurer très
légèrement le bouton bas de la manette
pour que l'hélico monte tout doucement
doucement.
Voilà, regardez bien, je suis en haut,
hein. Genre selon l'altimètre, je suis
en altitude et déjà maintenant, j'appuie
sur une touche de direction.
[ __ ] mais mais d'où d'où explique-moi
sur quoi je m'écrase en étant déjà en
l'air ? Comment je fais ? Je m'écrase
sur quoi ? Sur des nuages. Bref, bref,
bref. Devant une situation comme
celle-là, en général là, les joueurs ont
deux types de réaction. La première,
c'est de faire de la musique avec les
boutons sonores du jeu.
Et la seconde, c'est d'appuyer sur tous
les boutons. Et ben, en fait, ça a fini
par décoller, je sais pas comment.
Alors, maintenant que je suis en vol, il
y a un autre léger problème. Alors,
c'est son problème très très léger hein,
tu me diras. Mais mais quand même, je
fais quoi ?
Mais vraiment quand tu réussis à
décoller dans ce jeu, il y a absolument
rien d'indiqué. Tu es complètement lâché
sans savoir quoi faire. L'avion là, je
sais même pas si c'est censé indiquer
une direction ou quoi parce que ça bouge
n'importe comment. Select et start, ça
te fait bouger les lettres en bas, hein.
Chaque lettre correspond à une option
différente hein. Par exemple, le S c'est
la carte. Oui, S comme euh Smap.
Donc sinon, régulièrement dans le jeu,
c'est-à-dire une fois toutes les 12
secondes à peu près, un avion va te
survoler pour te demander ton
identification et à chaque fois bah il
faut faire la même manipe, c'est-à-dire
ouvrir la radio, lui répondre Overlord
ou Infiltrator et là ben tu as 50 % de
chance en fait qu'en fonction de ta
réponse, il te tire dessus ou qu'il soit
en fait un allié. Et c'est là que le
spectacle commence. Oh oui mon coco,
c'est là parce que ce jeu, il fait
tellement de trucs stupides et
irrationnels qu'il aurait presque sa
place au gouvernement parce qu'il y a
aucun moyen de différencier les avions
amis, des avions ennemis. C'est ça qui
est génial. Tu envoies une réponse au
hasard et tu as juste une chance sur
deux, soit la bonne. Et si tu as pas de
chance, mais tu peux reset directement
la console parce que si un seul missile
te touche, un seul missile, ça te
bousille au hasard une des pièces de ton
appareil. Parce que oui he ton hélico
est divisé en plusieurs parties :
moteur, armement, turbo, radio et
cetera. Et quand un missile te touche,
une de ces pièces au hasard se met à
clignoté pour indiquer qu'elle est
cassée. Sauf que à part le turbo, toutes
les pièces de ton appareil sont
cruciales. Si t'en manque une seule, tu
peux pas finir la mission. Si Wepon est
pété, tu peux plus tirer. Si
communication est pété, tu peux plus
envoyer de message. Si Engine est pété,
tu peux plus diriger ton hélico. Si
tactical est pété, tu vois carrément
plus la carte. Je fais comment pour
finir le niveau ? Je sais déjà pas où je
vais avec la carte. Comment je fais ça ?
[ __ ] je vois plus rien. Je suis
obligé de naviguer aux instruments.
Mais sérieusement, mais qui a conçu ce
jeu ? Enfin, ils sont tarés en un seul
coup. Ton appareil est foutu dans
n'importe quel autre jeu. Ça prend une
dizaine de coups. Mais là, un seul tir
et c'est cuit. Et il y a même des
boutons piégés. Si tu appuies sur le
turbo, ça te fait accélérer. Logique.
Mais le deuxième effet qui se coule,
c'est que ça explose ton moteur. Le
bouton turbo explose ton moteur. Mon
dieu, quel intérêt de mettre un bouton
sur ton propre hélicoptère qui explose
ton moteur.
[Musique]
Si encore j'avais le livret de ce jeu,
je pourrais peut-être comprendre, mais
les boîtes de jeunesse était tellement
pourri que sur une centaine de jeux, il
m'en reste pas une seule. Et d'ailleurs,
si j'avais le livré, je pourrais
peut-être aussi comprendre c'est quoi
tous ces trucs marqués dans ce jeu là.
Genre en haut, c'est quoi tous ces
machins ? E B O F A R. Au début, je
croyais que c'était les raccourcis des
pièces de l'hélicoptère, mais tu prends
les initiales, CD TTW, ça correspond
pas. Je sais même pas ce que c'est ce
machin. Ça arrête pas de clignoter. J'ai
pas reçu un seul missile et il y a déjà
des trucs qui clignotent partout dans
l'appareil. Pourquoi ça fait bip ?
Pourquoi ça clignote ? Tout ce jeu est
rempli d'écran qui font bip et qui font
flash. Ça fait bip et flash. Ça fait bip
et flash. Ça me rend fou des bip et des
flash. Ils veulent ma mort. Ils veulent
ma mort. Ils veulent ma C'est bon, je
suis calmé. Je suis calmé. Je suis
calmé. Ça va ?
Cela dit, vous savez, le pire c'est que
je suis persuadé que les développeurs de
ce jeu savaient eux-mêmes que c'était
impossible à passer puisque fait quand
tu regardes au début du jeu en fait, on
te donne la possibilité de choisir
directement ton niveau. On te donne la
possibilité de de sauter la phase
simulation. Je je suis sûr et certain
que quand les mecs ils ont essayé de
rejouer à leur propre jeu, ils se sont
rendus compte que c'était impossible et
du coup, ils ont mis cette option pour
éviter que les gens se tapent le niveau
1 en boucle. Donc nous y voilà hein dans
la seconde phase du jeu, celle qui
justifie le titre infiltrateor parce que
bon mine de rien, c'est vrai
qu'effectivement un hélico qui arrive
comme ça dans une base ennemie
niveau infiltration c'est pas top. Donc
dans cette partie on contrôle
directement le pilote, le personnage et
là on repart dans le délire de nouveau
puisque j'ai fait trois pas et je saute
sur une mine. Une mine ? C'est quoi cet
agent secret de merde là ? Le mec il
veut s'infiltrer pour espionner, il se
pose sur un champ de mine. Qui c'est
qu'on dirige sérieux ? Powers.
Bon, j'active le détecteur de mine. OK,
donc là, vous le voyez, il est activé,
hein. Vous le voyez bien, le timer est
en train de courir. C'est marqué en bas,
il est activé. Mais encore une fois, ça
marche comment ? Quand j'appuie dessus,
ça fait un bip.
OK, mais ça veut dire quoi bip ? Ça veut
dire que je suis près d'une mine, que
j'en suis loin. Et et si c'est si je
suis près d'une mine, alors elle est où
la mine ? Elle est en haut, en bas, à
gauche, à droite ?
E c'est c'est quand j'appuie, ça indique
rien. Sérieux, c'est c'est un détecteur
de mine ou c'est une machine à bip ce
machin là ? Enfin bref, de toute façon,
ce champ de mine, il sert à rien puisque
tu peux l'esquiver. En gros, d'ailleurs
toute cette partie pour résumer c'est
une mauvaise phase d'infiltration. Par
exemple, pour rentrer dans les bases et
changer d'uniforme même si le but
m'échappe un peu.
Ah, je suis infiltré le mand en bleu
mais moi je suis en orange. Enfin bon,
donc dans cette partie hein, chaque fois
que tu vas croiser un garde, il va te
demander tes papiers. Mais là, le pur
plaisir c'est que comme dans tout le
reste du jeu, c'est purement aléatoire.
Environ une fois sur trois, ça foire, ça
déclenche l'alarme et tous les gardes te
courent après. On sait ni pourquoi ni
comment. C'est aléatoire. Regarde-moi
ça. Là par exemple, je me fais contrôler
mes papiers par ce type. Je change de
salle. Je reviens immédiatement dans la
même salle. Le même mec me recontrôle
encore une fois et là, les papiers sont
plus valables. Mais pourquoi ? Pourquoi
? Pourquoi ? Pourquoi ? Pourquoi ?
Pourquoi ?
C'est encore tes papiers devenaient
moins valables. Genre au fur et à mesure
que le timer des papiers diminue, genre
ça devient de moins en moins efficace,
il y aura une certaine logique. Mais des
fois le premier mec que tu croises dans
la mission refuse tes papiers. Sérieux ?
Mais c'est quoi cette infiltration de
clochard ? Qui lui a fait ses papiers ?
Attendez, ces papiers sont pas valables.
Ah voilà, c'est parce que je suis black,
hein. Non mais franchement, mais ça me
dépasse. Pourquoi dans ce jeu je je
contrôle rien ? Je je veux dire, ce jeu
est encore pire que les jeux durs
puisque dans les jeux durs, tu sais
qu'au bout d'un moment, tu peux y
arriver en devenant très très bon. Mais
là, non. Là, tout est basé sur la
chance. De toute façon, j'ai aucune idée
de ce qu'il faut faire. Il y a un timer
qui tourne là. Il me reste 8 minutes.
Mais 8 minutes, pour faire quoi ? On
débarque dans cette base, on sait pas
quoi faire. Il y a bien des objets
explosifs dans les options, mais j'en ai
zéro. J'ai retourné toutes les salles
des trois bâtiments du niveau. J'ai rien
vu, aucun objectif, rien que des salles
remplies de meubles. Et les meubles, tu
peux oublier parce qu'au début, oui, tu
les fouilles un par un, même si c'est
rempli de truc inutile, mais quand tu
touches à ta 20e ou 30e salle sans rien
trouver, crois-moi que tu arrêtes de les
fouiller.
Oh [ __ ] et cette alarme qui tourne en
boucle, ça aussi ça me les brise. Ah,
pourquoi dans tous les jeux que je
teste, il y a toujours une alarme
quelque part qui doit crever lespans ?
C'est vraiment indispensable. Quoi ?
[Musique]
Quoi ? La bord de sortie du bâtiment
dans directement dans la rivière.
Vilain le jeu méchant jeu. Méchant jeu.
Tu es un méchant jeu. Méchant. Bon, faut
quand même relativiser cela dit he vous
savez ce genre de jeu en fait ils ont
souvent le mauvais rôle parce que ce
sont souvent des jeux qui sont hyper
répétitifs. Mais bon, même si c'est des
merdes hein, ils font quand même partie
de notre enfance. Et donc ben en
conséquence, il faut quand même garder
une place pour eux dans notre cœur.
Vous allez la fermer ?
[Musique]